is there something you could say to the
timeline that you think about uh about
the development of AGI
depending on the day I'm sure that
changes for you but when do you think
there'll be a really big leap in
intelligence where it would definitively
say we have built AGI do you think it's
one year from now five years from now 10
20 50.
what's Your Gut say
honestly
for the past decade I've deliberately
given very long timelines because I
didn't want to fuel some kind of stupid
Morlock race yeah but I think that cat
has really left the bag now
uh I I think it might be very very close
I I don't think that Microsoft paper is
totally off when they say that there are
some glimmers of AJ it's not AGI yet
it's not an agent there's a lot of
things it can't do but um
I wouldn't bet very strongly against it
happening
very soon that's why we decided to do
this open letter because you know if
there's ever been a time to pause
uh you know it's today
there's a feeling like this gpt4 is a
big transition into waking everybody up
to uh the effectiveness of these systems
yeah and so the next version
will be big yeah and if that next one
isn't AGI maybe the next next one will
and there are many companies trying to
do these things
um the basic architecture of them is not
some sort of super well kept secret so
this is this is the time to um
a lot of people have said for many years
that there will come a time when we want
to pause a little bit
that time is now